可是这几天就是收到我前夫的，
他好像起诉我，
我们当时是这样子的哈，
原因就是他是民次，
就是当时我们在婚内的时候，
他妈给了我们10万，
因为当时我们做点小生意嘛，
然后给了我们，
那后来呢，
也没有说让我们还过这个呢，
就是被我们去开销啊什么的都花销掉了，
这个情况下，
19年我们分开了以后，
当时是因为如果我不写这个，
我这个我就分不了，
我就写了一张，
呃，
那个欠条，
后来我们分开了以后，
就是我经济也不好，
也有付那个，
所以就一直到了19年的时候，
然后他妈就认时我去看女儿，
女儿是当时是在他们家上学，
我只是周六周日我接过来，
我们那个写的是父母不养哦，
不让我看，
就必须要逼着我再写，
要么我自己还，
我说我真没有能力写到二三年，
我又写了一次，
现在他手上就有我三张那个，
我写了那个，
然后现在就是已经接到电话，
说让我11月8号就去，
现在我的问题是啊，
我觉得虽然我写了那个三张，
但是我当时都是我是被逼无奈写的，
我不写我就分不开，
而是我又送不了女儿，
其次这个实话是当时我们共同花掉的，
不是说我一个人，
我觉得是不是不。
那怎么样，
当时他的这里是不是也不是应该让我一个人来承担，
你写的那个欠条具体是怎么写的，
我只写的是借了我前夫的，
我是欠他10万，
然后弟于年底还，
就这样子的，
就写了一张这样子的，
没有写了他妈的名字，
就写了他的名字，
欠他10万块钱，
有写是因为什么，
没有什么打给你的，
然后这钱花到哪里去了，
有写这些吗？
都没写，
就第一张欠两就险，
就今借到良成10万，
然后大姐的10万定于一九年内还清，
就是有一个这样子，
那你这个官司还有的可打，
有的可打是什么意思呢？
因为虽然你写了你从他那儿借了10万块钱，
从你前夫那借了10万块钱，
但实际上你前夫没有给你10万块钱的这个证据，
你也有1万块钱的转账记录，
那这个事儿还有的可打，
有一定的这个可能性，
就这事儿，
如果当时是写的欠条是，
嗯，
你啊欠你的婆婆10万块钱钱，
你的婆婆有给你转10万块钱的这个记录的话，
那基本就没跑了，
就没法没什么可打的了，
你就认栽吧，
就给钱就完事儿了，
你知道吧，
嗯，
至于说认定是夫妻共同的债务的话。
啊，
可能你给一半，
就是你最多能打，
打成这样，
就是是你最多能打成的那个结局了，
但现在是你写的欠条是欠你前夫10万块钱，
且欠条里面写的明确的是说今借到某某某十万块钱，
这个，
那这个事有的可打，
因为你没有管他借过钱，
他没有给你打过钱，
你应该借过吗？
如果我啊，
如果你要打这个事儿的话，
你还是花钱找律师吧，
就这事还值得打一打，
知道吧，
我应该去找个律师，
那我要设计什么那个资料的负责了吗？
就是你现在需要去配合你的律师的事，
在这个过程当中，
你们有没有别的聊天记录，
有没有别的什么，
呃，
转款的记录，
有没有其他的证据可以把你摁死。
没，
没有，
他那个给我的信息上，
他把他的证据都传了，
就是这个三张这个借条，
而且借条都是后面两张借条，
我只写了欠他多少多少，
就是什么豪候华就是写了这样的，
也没有选其他的还有的可打，
而且如果他到时候再拿出他妈妈的转账记录，
拿出这些所有的东西去证明，
说这10万块钱实际上他妈妈是债权人或者怎么样的话，
你还可以主张，
就是说这是我们夫妻两口子用掉的，
即便是欠你妈妈的钱的话，
那我也是还一半，
对，
我当时就是说我我只还一半，
他不同意，
然后还起诉我。
还有一点我想问一下啊，
当时我们结婚的当天，
他给了我十万彩礼，
但那一天我就给他父母了，
因为我当时听到他说父母说没钱什么什么的吧，
我当天我给到他的时候，
放他爸妈房间的桌子上，
我说之前我放你这里，
我当时是这么讲的，
如果是说我这个书掉了，
这个是不是也可以举你有证据吗？
那当时是现金，
当天晚上给他的也没有啊是哎，
我跟你说你得有证据，
你比如说你跟他爸妈聊天的时候，
你录音了，
你说爸妈当初你们是给了我10万块钱的彩礼啊，
我很感谢你们对我的这个认可啊，
但是我当时考虑到。
你们的，
呃，
经济条件也不好，
我把这10万块钱有你得有这样一个证据在呀，
你知道吗？
从法律上来说，
如果这个彩礼是在你领结婚证之前啊，
就给到你的，
这个彩礼算作你的婚前个人财产，
如果这个彩礼是在你俩领结婚证之后才给到你的这个彩礼，
10万块钱有可能就被定义成夫妻共同的财产，
而你又把这个彩礼又给到他们了，
这个事儿怎么认定呢？
对吧？
从老百姓的角度来说，
那退了就是退了，
就相当于没给。
嗯嗯，
明白，
我是领证之后给的，
我们是提前领证的，
那我我听你的意思，
我是不是可以，
比如说我现在跟她录音，
是我跟前夫还是跟婆婆录音，
说这个事情能不能以后作为正确跟公公婆婆，
因为你那个钱是退给公公婆婆的呀。
我我告诉你这个事儿啊，
充其量只能保护一下你，
但是他跟那个借款的事儿是两码事儿，
为什么说这个事儿中间只能保护一下你呢？
我怕就怕人家到时候拿着那个什么当时给你彩礼的证据来要求你退彩礼，
你知道吧，
他也是现金，
也没有证据啊。
那可不一定，
人家可能照的，
人家可能有对吧，
当时有录相啊，
给你现在去留一个证据，
证明你把彩礼退给他们老两口了，
其实是保护的你不再被他们追究彩礼这个事儿，
嗯，
明白明白了啊，
我再问一个问题啊，
就是其实这个过程当中，
就是这三张欠条是对我的一那个最不利的，
对吧，
如果我当时我没有写这三张，
是不是他压根就起示不了，
是不是这个意思？
也不一定，
因为当时他妈妈给这个钱的时候，
没说是赠予，
也没说是借，
那最终到底怎么认定，
到底是赠予给你们的，
还是借你们的，
还得看你们生活当中那些点点滴滴的留下来的证据，
比如当时啊，
婆婆有一句，
哎呀，
这钱就给你们了，
你们好好过日子，
一句给你们了，
可能就把他摁死了，
是郑赠予，
你知道吗？
比如说人家一一那个录个音说，
哎，
你们这10万块钱什么时候还给我们老两口啊，
你没有否认有这样一个录音在，
可能就把这个钱摁成了借款了，
你知道吗？
嗯了，
这事儿啊，
这事还两说，
嗯，
对的，
就是啊，
因为我女儿当时是我们写的，
是共同抚养，
我是以前我们就是教育啊什么的，
我们都是双方共同共同承担的，
从今年9月份，
从去年我女儿一直说不想在他那边想孩来我这边上学，
我好好签这一个问题，
就是要把他的那个，
他的这个户口本迁过来，
迁过来她又让我写了一张，
就是说以后所有女儿的生活费、
教育费全权由我来承担，
他不负任何责任，
不承担任何，
我当时没有办法，
因为女儿在旁边，
我不希望把我女儿看到这样子，
所以我有钱了，
那这个是不是也是对我不好，
我真服了你了，
大姐，
你什么事情？
都是先签了再说，
先签了再说，
大姐你脑子里面你你你是一个成年人，
因为你说什么东西都已经签了，
我问你现在孩子多大。
建赛现在孩子9岁了，
他可以选择跟谁了，
你如果想要孩子的抚养权的话，
并且你不想支付那些费用的话，
你就去起诉，
要求变更孩子的抚养权归你，
一旦孩子的抚养权变更给你了，
就不存在你再给孩子抚养费这个概念了，
他现在是一分钱不给，
什么也都付，
他就觉得他写了张欠啥了也后一旦孩子的抚养权归你了，
那么就该他给抚养费了啊，
就这意意思，
嗯，
明白带孩子9岁了，
你去起诉的话，
孩子他只要铁了心的跟你，
你是有机会的，
这样的话，
你原来签的那个说你承担孩子抚养费这个事儿，
那就不作数了，
我这个傻妹妹什么事情都以先签了字，
签了字，
你你这么搞的话，
我跟你说啊，
你以后的人生当中不能这么搞，
人生当中你什么事你上来先签了字的话，
到时候你神仙也救不了啊。